Hi, Doug.
Hello.
How are you?
How's it going, ladies? Doing well. Feel like it's been too long.
Hey, Doug, been a while.
So.
This is.
Andy, I missed you.
Yeah.
Which is why I'm here. I miss you too.
Yep.
I missed you the appropriate amount.
Yeah.
Okay, at least we're clear.
I don't want to make you uncomfortable in any way, even halfway across the world.
Not at all. Not at all. Don't worry about it. How are you so far? How was entire April?
A blur, but good.
Same, same.
Yeah, last week I ended up in New York unplanned. So that was a lot. But good. It was good. I mean, we, I don't, the trip was good. The point of the trip was to close a deal that I don't know if it's been closed or not yet because they keep asking us freaking questions.
Okay.
How is it?
But we keep answering them, so we'll see. It's a good hit for us. It's A 70 user shop. Most of ours, as you know, are much smaller and a few are in that range and larger.
We'll see.
Gotcha. I have a gift for you, by the way. Look at this.
I sent it on the chat.
Okay.
Oh my gosh.
PH.
Just a bit of a photo. Yeah, just looking.
That's hilarious.
It's. It sits in chairs at restaurants.
Yes.
Okay.
Got it.
I gotcha. Yeah, same here. Same with IT by design anyway. April was a blur. Was very busy month, but you know, busy is good. Busy is sometimes fun. But yeah, left, right, and center.
Yeah.
Thank God Ayra is there, so we're hanging.
Ayra is the best.
Yeah, she is. Okay, go ahead, Ayra. Sorry for stealing your time.
Yeah.
And I mean, and I mean that in an appropriate way. Damn it.
I don't have anything to do but to work.
That's why. All right, I'm gonna share my screen now. Give me a second.
This is for the month of April.
Let me know once you see my screen.
Got it.
Yep, can see it.
Okay, thank you, Andy and Doug for joining our monthly service call. So that's not weekly, I haven't changed it. It should be monthly. Moving on to the agenda items, that's all the same. For a check-in, this is for you, Doug. Anything, any news you want to share with us?
I forgive you.
Yeah.
What, how's the performance of our guys?
Everything's going really well.
We are backfilling a little bit in New York, some L2 positions, so we're bringing more people on in New York for onsite stuff. So that should take some pressure off of Nigel. At least one of them will be trained and dispatched as well. So hopefully get some of that pressure off of him.
I expect, like, literally, I have somebody starting on Monday, a week from Monday, and the following Monday, so like one, two, three. So that's kind of terrible in its own way. I would love for them to all start on the same day. But, you know, we'll deal with that. And I fully expect one of them not to work out.
Yeah.
Oh.
just statistically speaking. So we'll see how it goes. They're all great in my mind. I just know I'm bad at hiring and at least one of them will be bad. You guys aren't that good either. Don't brag.
Yeah.
Well, I have Andy here if you need help.
I was about, I was about to say, I was like, I don't have like a track record just yet for a great time.
Yeah, you got nobody hits better than one than two out of three. Most people are hiring and the half the people they hire are terrible.
Yeah.
Exactly. They're just, you know, bad apples somewhere somehow. So he bound to pick him. But hey, if anything comes up, dog, we're here. I'm here.
I know. No, I essentially, I'm only hiring at this point in New York and with you guys. So if we see on-site need, we're doing New York. If we see remote, I wouldn't even hire me at this point. So
You're expensive. I wouldn't even hire you, so...
What? You know, I'm not that expensive. I'm A bargain.
and see all the business I bring in.
Okay.
But yeah, thank you for keeping still us in mind, just in case, you know, something comes up. Yeah, just, just holler.
Of course.
No, for sure. And like I said, anything that I can do remotely, I'm thinking of you guys. Anything else, we were light on our New York presence. And one of our guys left too. I don't know if you were in the loop on that. So we had one of our most senior guys stepped away. So
Appreciate that.
Mhm.
Yeah.
We are backfilling, so we'll be good.
AJ does all the training, so it's not my problem is getting the hires in the door and now he has to make them good. So see how that goes.
Art.
Cool.
Okay, hopefully everything turns out well. And if you need any help, Doug, we're always here. And for our guys, Sheila and Nigel, we're going to make sure that we're here for you to help you with the coverage. And for the highlights, yesterday, May 7th, yeah.
Kour.
we celebrated Nigel's birthday. So I bought him a little cake, a caramel cake. So he enjoyed it. And plus, yeah, our company continues to provide reliable coverage for you. Whenever you need help, we're always here. For performance analysis,
Nice.
It's all the same. The ITBD recommended KPIs. If you have questions for these, if you want to discuss something, let me know.
And moving on to utilization trend and analysis. This is for Nigel alone. We have the five-week trend. This is all for April. If we see here, his average utilization trend was 68.9%. The target
that we have is 80% and I checked in with him. The reason for the dip was because of the back end work, so most of them were non-billable. And I know that's understandable because he's helping out with the backup and thing on your end. Yeah, so that's that.
It's.
Yep.
Do you have questions for utilization trend?
None.
Okay, cool. For ticket closure trend, we have here the chart. So the average, we closed at 76.5 for April. The peak was on April 13th. He closed. That was 82% for the resolution rate.
So if we're going to sum up the total ticket closed for April that he closed 143 tickets, so that's good. The average was 7. So one more to go because our target is 8 to 10. So good thing that he closed 7 tickets per day.
for April. So we're working on, I'm working very closely with Nigel. I was talking to him the other day and he was actually looking forward to work on more back-end work. So we will see a dip in his utilization trend for May.
Sorry, it's Friday.
No, you're good.
Plus, if you need help, if there are any projects that we need to work on with Nigel, apart from the backup or any server patching and everything, you can let us know so we can prepare him beforehand. Okay?
Sounds good.
All right.
Mhm.
Appreciate the quick turnaround. So this is for the month of April. I just took two.
Nice, and Nathan is our is our just just a little bit of commentary. Nathan is our primary point of contact over there, so impressing him is super important.
Here are the ITBD, Nathan.
PH.
Wow. Yeah, I always hear Nigel is very good with customer satisfaction. It's customer communication skills. It's excellent. It's really good. Yep. For IT by design products, you already know this. If you have questions or if you want to avail any...
Wow.
Of these products, you can let us know.
For the way forward, I want to check in if you have work on the coming May 25th, that's the Memorial Day. Do you need our guys?
Nope, we'll be we'll be off that day.
Okay, cool. And these are the upcoming PDOs. I have received your approval for this, so thank you so much. Nigel will be out on May 11th and 12th. And upcoming video for Sheila, yeah, she's on PDO today. Yeah. Okay, for C, set and end.
Yeah.
Today, yeah.
P.S. Andrea, did we receive the feedback from Doug already?
Let me check. Did you fill it out, Doug? Were you able to receive any?
I think I just smiley-faced in this month. I did it twice.
Please.
I got, I got two rounds of them.
That's OK.
Oh yeah, I got, we got it for April for Atlantic PC. All good.
Okay, same goes with NPS.
Uh, NTS. Let me see.
Ohh.
Help you check it too.
Mm.
Atlantic Crazy. Yep. You gave us a 10 out of 10. Wow. Thank you very much.
Okay.
Wow.
I like you guys. You guys do a good job. Guys do a better job than I do.
PH.
Thank you, Doug, for your support.
Yeah.
You make me look good. It's all good. Appreciate both of you.
Thank you very much, Matt.
Thank you. All right. What else?
All right, I hope, was that it? Oh, sorry, I didn't mean to cut us out. It felt like, it felt like a conclusion. No, no, we're good.
No, it's okay. You can go ahead.
I think we covered just about everything.
I have one though. Um, he coming to build it? August.
You should, you must.
I think so. I would like to. Are you guys gonna count my ticket?
Have you registered?
I would, yes. So I would love to meet you there.
I've.
I would. Okay. Shoot me the dates again. I'd love to come. And it's in New Jersey, so I can dovetail it with a New York trip. What about you guys? Are you guys going?
Okay.
Uh-huh.
Yeah.
I am going and then New York, August 35, and that's my birth month, dog, so.
Wow, a whole month we have to celebrate your birthday, huh?
Yes.
Exactly, which is why I got to meet you there. I'll tell you the email. I'll say.
All right. Yeah, no, I would love to. I got a check against my vacation time and things like that, but I would love to. What about Ayra? Ayra needs to get to the state.
Mhm.
I will pack her up in my luggage so that I can take her away. I think that's the only way I can take that. You can have two of us out for a week, man. I think this is, this place is gonna get into shambles if that happens. But yeah, I would love her to come next time.
Yeah.
I get that, I get that.
But if I can still see her in a luggage, I think that would be okay. I'll send you the email. I'll include the QR. I can just register there. It's in August 3 to 5. So the last day of that, it's more of about AI. So if you wanted to leverage that, there would be a lot of speakers as well. If you wanted to speak.
Good.
Okay.
And.
OK.
Man, let me know. I'll add you to the list.
Oh, I'm a terrible public speaker. You don't want me to do that.
PH.
So yeah, I'll send you an email. I'll send you an email right after this. If you wanted to bring someone along, I think we have that BOGO promo. So buy one, get one. So let me know.
Really bad.
Kour.
Okay, cool. Yeah, I'll check it out. It looks like I won't be traveling that week, so I should be around.
Hey.
Kour.
For, for the for I pasted it on our chat, so if you need the details and Andy will send it to you as well, the email, so just a sneak peek. So, I'm good on my end, Doug and Andrea. If you need any help for Nigel and Sheila, you can always ping me. OK.
Okay, anything else?
Yep.
Yeah.
Sounds great.
Sure. Thank you so much. Have a good day. Happy weekend. Lanzaga.
Happy weekend! Bye-bye.
Bye.